this is going to set the industry back
years people have lost a lot of
confidence in cryptocurrency simply
because of what has happened I would say
do not worry mainly because this isn't
an issue about cryptocurrency this is an
issue of human corruption human error
and human greed that's simply all it is
that's why these conversations are so
important because we have to give
education and teach people we do not
want them leaving their cryptocurrency
on these centralized exchanges
particularly exchanges that have been
working so closely with the SEC for the
last six months somehow the SEC had no
idea that this company were insolvent
that's another story so we want to teach
these people that actually they can buy
their crypto on these centralized
platform but then remove it and take
self-custody put it in a non-custodial
wallet where only you hold the keys it
doesn't matter what happens to a company
if it goes and solve it you don't have
to trust a centralized entity all you do
is you trust the blockchain and that's
the best thing to do